[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Marcus is
in Oklahoma City hey Marcus welcome to
the Ramsey Show hey D how are you better
than I deserve what's up uh I'll just be
quick and to the point 2020 2021 I was
working a mortgage company um they
closed their doors in 2022 I was making
quite a bit uh now I'm a teacher didn't
file my taxes for 2020 and 2021 um
probably 80% of that was um obviously
commission so I did dumb uh I know I
need to file those now obviously and I'm
gonna owe quite a bit I was just going
to see if I can maybe get some um advice
on how to go about doing that in the the
least harmful
way
ouch okay here here's the thing not
paying taxes is not a criminal act not
filing taxes is is a criminal
act that's what's weird we do not have a
debtor's prison they don't put people in
jail for not paying their taxes but they
do put people in jail about 2500 a year
for failure to file okay so that's where
that's the danger that you're in I'm
more concerned about that than I am the
payment plan I don't think you're in
trouble and because 99% of the time that
you're not some Pol not some public
figure that you you come and self F you
know you catch up your filings they're
just all late um you don't get into any
criminal issues but I want you to get it
done now I don't want them to come find
you okay I want you to go to them like
immediately no later than the middle of
January these documents need to be filed
okay yes sir you know that's the Panic
then the second issue is how do we pay
it well number one we've got to assess
the damage and figure out from the
actual filings what you actually
owe and then um you know your worst case
scenario is you're selling some stuff
and putting uh the KGB I mean the IRS on
a payment
plan okay so uh because I mean if you
were doing mortgage origination in 2020
you made some Bank yes sir yeah like
what' you make that year probably 2 250
and you paid zero taxes yes
sir did you save any
yeah yeah got got about uh probably a h
100,000 save oh good okay because you're
probably GNA have a $100,000 tax bill oh
yeah okay if you got two years of that
you will yeah easy yeah so you're going
to give them what you got to limit it
and then you're going to work out the
payments what you've got to have is a
real tax Pro in your corner right now
and if you'll go to ramseys
solutions.com and click on the tax ELP
for your area there and in Oklahoma City
I know them they're good people they can
sit down with you and help you first get
the filings done and then secondly
negotiate the payment plan and how much
of this you got to throw at them to keep
them off your bank account because we
don't want them putting leans on
everything after you file but also don't
want them putting bracelets on you that
connect because you didn't
file yes sir so we need to get filed and
uh and then we need to develop the the
how tough the path is that we've got to
walk through do you own a home yes sir
what's it
worth uh about 500 what do you owe about
200 okay well and and what is your
household income
nowadays um probably about 70 I have
three jobs right now so I'm a teacher i'
do some data entry at night and I do
wait some tables on the weekends you
have any money other than the
hundred uh no you have any money in
retirement you have money in retirement
I do okay all right I do not tell people
to cash out retirement for um for to pay
off debt I might to pay off the IRS to
keep from selling your
home you follow me so that's what you've
got to get into you've got to ascertain
because let's just say this okay let's
say it's 150 and you throw a 100 down
and you say okay we're going to pay uh
20 or we're going to pay $1,000 a month
for three years and will be out of debt
that's okay but if it's a if it's 200
and you put a 100 down and you're going
to be in debt for a decade you don't
want that you need to you need to clean
out something else the house or the
retirement accounts and clean up the
mess so the not filing and it's not the
not filing the not paying and the not
filing I hope it's not a ton more than
the 100 when you get there it's going to
be something more than that but you you
need to get you need
to understand the size of the the
problem the uh the not knowing is a
bigger stress inducer than knowing the
details so you've got the cancer
diagnosis you just don't know what the
treatment is yet and you don't know
whether it's
terminal you you know so that first
thing they do is they scare you to death
and you go around for about two months
with or two weeks with no information
and then they start going okay well
here's the treatment plan Oh you mean
I'm not going to die well that would
have been handy information about a week
ago you know and that's kind of what
you're dealing with here is that same of
emotions so
um you know the uh uh yeah get with a
tax Pro today when you hang up open up
Ramsey solutions.com click on taxpro ELP
at uh Oklahoma City and go sit down with
them this week I don't give a crap if
it's Christmas uh you know you need to
give yourself a gift to getting this
monkey off your back oh man that's scary
yeah and I hope he has he saves some
money I hope he also has some writeoffs
and records of that kind of stuff um so
that he can you know the better the
better your records the more you can
limit this yes that's exactly right
writeoffs and Records tax Pro here is
huge though do not try to figure this
out on your own no and don't go ask the
IRS what to do oh yeah good Lord yeah
it's like asking a dog if it's hungry
you know no we don't do that so you know
where did you get your tax information
from the IRS oh my God you're a fool you
know no no no no no no no we don't we
don't ask them we don't ask the fox
about the hen house hello yeah so yeah
oh oh yeah they're tasty and by the way
don't ask them for Grace either because
they don't have any U this is get your
tax Pro to help you gra I used to talk
to Grace no used to talk to her weekly
she called me all the time it's like
from Christmas Vacation she died 10
years
ago yeah yeah they they're just not
going to be kind and a tax Pro here is
going to be your Advocate and they know
everything that they they can do they're
they're worth it so don't try to
navigate this on your own yeah and and
there's and here's the last part of this
okay the these commercials that are on
cable TV do you have $10,000 or more in
tax debt we can get it forgiven we have
X IRS agents working for us just give us
$5,000 and we will promptly do nothing
for the next 24 months that's what that
is that's a complete freaking scam
there's a thing called the OIC an offer
in compromise that you can get your
federal income taxes forgiven about 1%
of of them are approved you have to
prove total popers ship meaning you
don't have a house you don't have a job
you don't have any potential income and
you don't have any assets of any kind
and then they will forgive your debt
after fooling with them for about 2 and
a half years don't answer those stupid
butt cable tv ads go get a tax Pro and
actually work a plan to get the mess
cleaned up create your free every dooll
budget today the simplest way to budget
for your life